[Musique]
vous la sentez vous cette tension
sociale et comment est ce que vous la
gérez un ton professeur alors on l'a on
la ressent on la ressent au quotidien
par des difficultés qui se trouvent dans
l'intérieur des établissements en termes
de climat scolaire aux et à l'extérieur
des établissements aussi il ne faut pas
évidemment cacher les réalités
difficiles que connaît ce que
connaissent les quartiers populaires
avec des difficultés aux abords des
établissements des affrontements qu'on
connaît aussi dans la ville injecte dans
l'expresso scolaires qui sont extra
scolaire mais qui ont une influence
effectivement sur sur l'école pour
autant on ne trouvera pas de solution si
l'on fait de l'école un territoire qui
est à côté des quartiers dans lesquels
elle s'inscrit il faut au contraire
évidemment développé le justement la
relation de l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative dialoguer avec les parents
dialoguer avec les différents
professionnels mais c'est pas une et
c'est pas étonnant qu'on est con et ce
genre de ce genre de tensions les
politiques actuelles aussi vide par
exemple de leurs moyens de leurs moyens
humains et les antennes jeunesse la
disparition de certains contrats qui
était certes précaire mais qui existait
dans l'est dans les quartiers populaires
sont cons les interlocuteurs les
interlocutrices dans les services
publics ne sont plus là en clair et pour
résumer pour résumer les choses je pense
que il y à une organisation concertée
d'une destruction du service public
d'éducation comme on peut avoir dans
d'autres services publics aussi elle est
accompagnée n'at on dit souvent les
parents
ne veulent plus inscrire leurs enfants
dans les établissements de ses leaders
on observe que pour comment comment
comment on perds ton ont fait
dysfonctionné un service public pour
faire rentrer en fait le loup dans la
bergerie à savoir la privatisation
rampante une intervention de certaines
associations d'orientation par exemple à
capitaux privés de fondations privées
systématiquement faire dysfonctionné un
service public qui ça permet ensuite de
faire rentrer l'idéologie de la start up
nation qu'on a en place à l'heure
actuelle
[Musique]